this is what a long-distance marriage
during a pandemic looks like
ian martin and his wife pooja first
bonded at a book fair
he says 98 of their relationship is now
conducted via whatsapp
it's not easy we we're in constant touch
with each other and we we talk on skype
almost every day
um but obviously there's things we'd
like to be doing like you know starting
a family or
whatever and these things have all been
put on hold
i haven't quite moved in i'm waiting for
my husband to join me
while ian remains stuck in colchester
waiting for a u.s
green card pooja is in washington d.c
getting things ready for the day
they can finally be together i bought
this condo here as our home and i've
been setting it up
but making all the decisions about color
and flooring and
how to furnish is really challenging on
your own when it was intended to be for
both of us
so there's a lot of whatsapp and skype
and a lot of screenshots being sent back
and forth
we're making the best of it but it's
been really challenging
living apart from one another the couple
have spent just four weeks of their 19
months of married life together
and are desperate for a uk u.s travel
corridor
i would politely ask mr biden to look
at the current restrictions and see if
there is any
any exemptions that can be made any any
way of reopening that travel corridor
um i'm not entirely convinced i would
waste much breath
discussing anything with the british
prime minister because he doesn't really
seem to have his
hands on the levers there does it upset
you
hugely hugely i mean i'm i'm still doing
that thing of trying to put a brave face
on it now but you know i've been married
for
19 20 months at this point and i've had
so little
time with my wife the organization love
is not
tourism has put together a global task
force trying to reunite
separated families fifty percent of
their global community haven't seen
their partner since the pandemic began
50 say they hadn't suffered mental
health problems prior
to the separation 87 say
they're now worried about their mental
health what we're asking for is just
people in those uni in our unique
circumstances
just a bit more freedom and leeway in
terms of able to travel
a bit more often and um and see our
partners
ultimately um because if you look at the
current situation in the uk
where you've got most countries under
amber and red people just
let alone them at the cost of pure
testing to go to go abroad and come back
the time of having to come back and then
quarantine for 10 further days off work
a lot of people just can't do that
the government says it's working on a
balancing act between
reopening international travel and
protecting the vaccine rollout from new
variants
but for couples like ian and pooja that
travel corridor
can't come quick enough and the brady
sky news